now there was more evidence of the Trump
effect in New York earlier today well
this was the reaction when trading began
at a City Stock Exchange
[Applause]
and this was the reason why the Dow
Jones Industrial Average went through
the 20,000 point barrier for the first
time in its history scott shellady also
known as the cow guys a trader at t JM
brokerage he joins us now live from
Chicago Scott courtesy what if investors
heard from Trump that driven this well I
mean he's got three main tenants he's
talking about reducing taxes he's
talking about reducing a lot of
regulation which is kind of stymied some
of our small businesses here and then
and then we've also got a trillion
dollar spending plan or infrastructure
spending plan or a bill that's on the
table as well so you put those three
together and it's kind of hard to want
to get in front of that railway train
what's interesting is it took us five
weeks to kind of get over that hurdle
which was only about a hundred points
away the whole time so in five weeks we
it took us you know that long to get
over this hundred points to make this
twenty thousand now we need to see the
proof in the pudding we're going to need
to see the economic indicators come
through and tell us that yes some of the
things that he's done as far as keeping
jobs here manufacturing jobs here
keeping some of the companies here as
well those types of things need to kind
of flow through the but to the bottom
line this we can kind of make sure this
move is for real which I think it is
there's a lot of money on the sidelines
but it's now I'm gonna have to get
involved okay Scott I'll just give you a
bit of breaking news that we've just
heard from the Reuters news agency which
is that Donald Trump's just signed an
executive order on border security we'll
have more on that later in the program
of course the down trading by some
measures on 28 times earnings now that's
pretty topping no one seems to be
worrying too much about company earnings
right now well I think Wall Street's
giving him a pass on it because you know
again if you take our tax rate to 15 to
20 percent he initially wanted 15 but
he's wiggling a little bit on that so 15
or 20 percent on our taxes which is a
big deal and then he wants yesterday or
two days ago he said something about
reducing regulations by 75% and then on
top of that a trillion dollar
infrastructure spending plan I mean
that's gonna get things going now let's
remind ourselves right a few short
months ago let's say three months ago
maybe at the most we had a president who
for the first time in 86 years went his
entire term about one-quarter of three
percent growth all right
the first time in 86 yet yet he outspent
all 43 other presidents before him
combined now that doesn't work that
doesn't that's not good that doesn't
tell you that the US economy is in good
shape so he's outspent every other
president before him in total all right
and he still couldn't get three percent
growth we're gonna have to have a sea
change of psychology and I think that's
what Trump's bringing to the table
Wall Street's giving him a pass we'll
see if his three-point plan works and
then we'll have to take a look at those
earning you know the price earnings
ratios yeah briefly scope the Dow Jones
is it that meaningful I mean a fifth of
this rise since November is down to
shares in goldman sachs alone Goldman is
weighted at twice in the index at Apple
is even though Apple six times the size
is it that meaningful and index you're
exactly right to the to the Main streets
and that mainstream by mainstream -
right it is because that's something
that they all maybe follow but if you're
in the industry we look at the S&P 500
it's much more of a broader index to
give you a much better idea about the
health and wealth of the economy the Dow
is too small and so like the other
players like you just mentioned have too
much of a stake in it then it kind of
distorts how things are but the
mainstream media the first thing that
we'll put on the news tonight it's gonna
be 20,000 I guarantee you they're not
gonna put the S&P 500 up even though of
course yes in peace hit an all-time high
as well today right exactly right so the
one that really gets the headlines still
is the Dow and the New York Stock
Exchange and will let them do that but
at this at the same time remember the
proof is going to be in the pudding
we're gonna need to see the economic
indicators come in and really kind of
shore up these prices here or you can
see things pull back